I'm going to start with quite a stupid
question if I may um you are president
of the World Bank can you just explain
to our viewers what is the World Bank
what does it do
yeah thanks hi Sophie the world bank
takes in money from donors in two ways
one is we sell shares uh and we also
take annual contributions and then we
provide that to developing countries so
the goal is to get better outcome for
people in developing countries we
recognize that's part of uh being good
citizens in the world but also it
supports everyone if you can get faster
growth in the poorer countries that's
been the big challenge you know it it's
uh it's not happening right now and
that's a grave concern it's interesting
you say that it's not happening right
now uh why do you think that is
the poor countries are facing this giant
challenge that uh the the advanced
economies use a lot of the world's
resources and now you've got these
sudden uh uh uh obstacles covid was one
obviously the Russia's invasion of
Ukraine is adding to food costs and to
fertilizer costs uh and the countries
are cut off from World Markets so you
get this combination of forces that
causes them to fall into recession but
it's worse than that it's really uh the
the reversal and development poverty is
getting worse education levels are going
down in many of the developing countries
so it's incumbent I think on the World
to do a lot more the World Bank has been
really expanding our efforts across the
developing world
you talk about the war in Ukraine you
also mentioned the impact of covid as
well
what's happening when it comes to debt
with developing countries
that is a huge challenge uh part of the
debt is in the advanced economies you
know many of them have uh recorded debt
to GDP levels and that soaks up a uh a
big portion of the world's Capital which
means it's not available for small small
businesses and for developing countries
that's a misallocation of capital and I
think it should be really directly
looked at by the advanced economies to
make their spending more efficient and
then as you look at the developing
countries uh some of them uh overused
the low interest rate environment to
borrow over the last decade so the debt
went up way up uh where we're at record
levels uh and that's coming at a time
when they're uh when their growth rates
and their new investment rates have gone
way down you know I remember you know I
think it was back in the G8 in 2005.
there's a big focus on debt reduction on
forgiveness on on writing off debt
you're obviously now worried as many are
that poorer countries are overloaded
with debt again do you think some of
that should be written off
yes I I think there needs to be a a hard
look at uh large amounts of debt
reduction by the official bilateral
creditors and also the private sector
creditors the composition of debt has
changed over that period that you name
over the last 10 years heavily toward
debt from China and also debt from the
private sector it's interesting you
mentioned the high levels of loans from
China should we be concerns about
China's influence in the developing
world
China is uh the world's second biggest
economy so I think we should expect
their their influence in the developing
World they do it both by selling things
uh into the developing world but also by
buying uh uh raw materials and by uh
offering debt so what we have strongly
advocated and I was in in China late in
2022 uh We've advocated transparency in
their debt contracts uh in that way
people can restructure them or can at
least understand what the commitments
are that are being made by the poorer
countries that transparency means don't
include non-disclosure Clauses in a
contract making it a secret contract
that that seems to still be going on
even today there's been a few things in
the interview so far that you've called
for uh to happen you know if you could
you know wave your magic wand and have
one piece of policy across the world to
make things better what would you choose
so much of the money is taken up by the
advanced economies I think there's a big
burden to be as efficient as possible in
government spending that that would be a
signal a forward signal to the markets
that there was going to be Capital
available for others and that would
allow the investment flows to to uh be
become more balanced that would provide
money in the poor countries for
education and for health uh and for
climate adaptation which is so
desperately needed and for food as we
were discussing uh before but right now
there's uh just not an availability of
capital at the World Bank where we have
a major effort underway with our
shareholders to look for more resources
and to use the resources as effectively
as possible to meet the needs of people
in poor countries and just finally you
know we're kind of edging towards the
end of January now what are your
predictions for 2023 do you think things
are going to ease up when it comes to
the world economy or do we have tough
times ahead
I think it's a long lasting slowdown
it's not exactly a cycle the way we've
been used to in the past uh and that has
to do with the Persistence of inflation
the shortage of new investment that's
taking place right now so as you look
one year ahead in two years ahead uh
it's hard to see that there'll be a
strong recovery that that puts burden on
the uh on policy makers to make
decisions now to have the spending be
more efficient that applies both to the
private sector and to the uh to the
governments to make their spending
really count uh so that there can be a
recovery going out into the future my
concern is it looks like the Slowdown or
this period of slow growth for the world
may last into 2023 24 uh and uh that's a
concern one other thing I'll mention is
when governments do subsidize their
citizens which is politically uh
necessary and attractive they they need
to have it be time bound uh and targeted
in other words rather than giving
benefits to everyone for the foreseeable
future uh do it for six months for the
narrowest group uh that is possible that
is hurt by the by the higher prices that
are occurring now when you say things
like if it's in spending and subsidizing
citizens
am I right and thinking what you mean by
that is tightening belts it's spending
less it's I guess austerity slightly
uh yes exactly uh and that means making
choices hard choices and this applies to
the developing world and even the
poorest countries there's inefficient
spending and so we work with the
countries uh to to improve that one
example is uh on on taxes where the
countries aren't collecting taxes maybe
from a select group of people that get
exemptions from taxes that's not fair to
everyone else and it doesn't get the
country through this long period of
slowdown so belt tightening if you want
to use that phrase yes thank you very
much it's been really interesting to
talk thank you